just talking that last caller before the
break reminding him that you know 10
years from today what are you aiming at
who are you going to be what do you want
to be doing what kind of income do you
want to have 20 years from today who are
you going to be what kind of income are
you going to have what are you aiming at
this executor used to say if you aim at
nothing you'll hit it every time and
most people am at nothing and that's why
we have a retirement crisis in America
because we have people that are aiming
at nothing they don't have a plan you
know their only plan is Costa long and
somewhere in the back of their mind
they're saying to themselves oh well as
your hope the government which is well
known for its ability to take care of
money will take care of me I mean
they're broke they're not going to take
care of you and Trump is not going to
make your life great and for dadgum sure
Hillary's not going to make your life
great if you're waiting on a president
to fix your life your life sign always
suck have you not figured that out yet
everybody's all torqued out and worried
about the election all worried about
who's going to get elected and whether
the world's going to come to an end
based on which which one of those
characters we put in the White House
they're both like cartoon characters
aren't they they're so bad character
issues are just unbelievable and you're
going to sit around and wait on them to
fix your life well you've got a long
wait I mean you remember people on the
street saying Obama got elected he's
going to change my life he didn't change
your life did he I hope and change thing
he changed some things he wanted to
change but he can change your life tell
me why your life is better no your if
your life's better it's because you went
and made it better you're the secret
sauce in your life you're the way it
happens and that's why Chris Hogan's
book retire inspired was the number one
bestseller when it came out because
people know that they know I mean
especially adults devised a plan and
follow it children do what feels good
adults know that if you're going to
retire inspired you're going to have to
do it and it's not it's not really bad
news it's just a statement of an obvious
fact your destiny is in your hands
thank goodness you're the secret sauce
to your future no one's going to fix
your life Bernie's not gonna fix your
life nobody's going to fix your life
your job is not even responsible you
would think that an employer don't wait
around on your employer to fix your life
they don't pay in half why are you
working there you're the stupid one
keeps going over there every day
you think they under pay you think
they're a bad company you think they're
low on integrity go get you a different
place to work darling it's called a free
country whine about what somebody pays I
think they had to pay more than minimum
wage then don't work there have some
skills more than minimum skills do
something with your life retire inspired
so Chris Hogan's got only two more stops
on his return inspired tour this fall
you ought to be at one of them he's
going to be in Los Angeles November the
10th and in Chicago November the 15th
and this event is going to be the
situation where you take the fear out of
this retirement thing if you're young
it's not too early to start and if
you're old it's not too late to start
you got to start because it's up to you
baby this is your deal it's only $39 to
go and get your tickets at Dave Ramsey
comm call call customer care at Triple
Eight 22 piece and they'll get you
signed up that you need to do something
like that you need to read a book if
your marriage is struggling do you think
it's just going to be fixed no you need
to read less Peretz books on marriage
you're struggling with your kids and
you're a doctor megameters books on
parenting you're struggling with
boundaries with your crazy family
members you need to read boundaries but
dr. Henry clout and on and on and on
right it's not gonna fix itself it's up
to you only you can change it you got to
work like it all depends on you and pray
like it depends on God all depends on
God so I can't stand it when people say
you're so lucky
honey luck had nothing to do with it 25
years of hard work and God's blessings
that's what did it
nothing else well you were blessed by
God yes I was and I worked my butt off
you worked your butt off yeah so us and
I was blessed by God it's both and it's
not or and dont's tell me you're so holy
you think it's only God because you
don't read the Bible then our sowing and
reaping in there a lazy farmer who
doesn't plant any seed has dirt that's
in the Bible
that's all you gets dirt you stand there
and look at the ground you know what you
got dirt and there's a lot of people
stand around looking at the ground of
their life and they plant nothing they
don't get rid of the weeds they keep
messing around with gambling and
pornography and drugs and everything
else they keep the weeds in their garden
of their life they never plant anything
positive into their life and then
they're shocked that they have a weed
filled garden that doesn't produce fruit
as a way of life as a life it's crazy
you keep the weeds out of your life and
you plant good seed in your life and you
will have a beautiful clean garden it's
Halloween and I went to my wife's garden
last night and there were still fresh
tomatoes that's whacked I don't know
when I've had fresh tomatoes and
Halloween but I you know all it is
she put good seed in the ground and she
weeded it hello there's not a bunch of
filth in that garden and there's stuff
in there they're supposed to be growing
the stuff we want it to be growing the
stuff we want and that's all and you
know Sharon's country girl she knows how
to do that so there you go it really
isn't any harder than that but people
sit and you know flip back and forth
from pornography on their computer they
drink too much smoking weed trying to
figure out how they're going to get on
with their life and why they can't get
ahead well that's why you can't get
ahead you got a garden full of weeds you
know you're messing around stuff that's
messing up your life your brain is very
very fertile ground it is going to
return a crop of what you plant in it
every single time and if you plant
poison you're going to get a bumper crop
of poison and if you plant stupid you're
going to get a bumper crop of desperate
I know I've done it
I've done it I'm not saying I mean
different I'm the same way you are so
you're so lucky when you look at someone
that has a good marriage good kids a
good life luck didn't anything do with
it's stupid kept the weeds out of your
life and plant good seed and then you
pray for God to rain on you blessings
but if he rains and pours out blessings
on weeds you know what you get more
weeds if he rains and pours out
blessings on dirt that has no positive
seed planet in it you know what you got
a mud puddle
it is both sides of this equation are
required for you to win your work your
discipline your clean and righteous
living and the way you conduct your
character in yourself and today with the
with social media the way it is the way
you conduct yourself is going to be an
electronic tattoo it's going to be with
you the rest of your life somebody's
going to bring that picture up 20 years
from now that you just took and post it
you really want that the other way you
really want to look is that how you
really want to be known saying stuff
like that doing stuff like that it's all
recorded now by some goop somewhere so
be who you are and be careful of who you
are this is the Dave Ramsey show hey
guys thanks for watching if you enjoyed
this video click the subscribe button to
get the latest content and check out
these other great clips from the show
you